so uh radical republican or maybe
confused republican senator lindsey
graham lindsey graham strikes me more as
confused than radical i guess although
every once in a while he will say
something pretty radical he suggested
assassinating vladimir putin and then
all hell broke loose and by the next day
there there was no more talk of
assassination instead he was talking
about arresting vladimir putin a much
more sober and modest suggestion but i
have to tell you
what lindsey graham said
is not dissimilar
to what is going on
in many intelligence
agencies back rooms it's just you can't
publicly say it i'm going to explain
what i mean so let's get to the first
clip this is lindsey graham uh in the
evening i think this was thursday night
where he said we need a plot we need
someone in there who's going to kill
putin the way there was a plot to kill
hitler how does this end
somebody in russia
has to step up to the plate is there
brutus in russia is there more
successful colonel stoppenberg in the
russian military the only way this ends
my friend is for somebody in russia to
take this guy out you would be doing
your country a great service and the
world of great service right
that's that's pretty full on for for a
senator in the united states to say the
best path is assassinating putin okay so
what is he talking about well he's
talking about uh stauffenberg
full name would be
klaus philip maria justinian shank graf
von stauffenberg this was a german army
officer
who um i guess we would say executed a
failed attempt in july of 1944 to
assassinate adolf hitler at the
so-called wolf's lair so
lindsay is saying we need something
similar we need someone from inside
russia
uh to take out vladimir putin so this
was
completely irresponsible to say
and obviously it's being considered i
mean we let's not let's not play dumb
here guys
there is no doubt
that every serious intelligence agency
and i'm not defending them from doing it
i'm just telling you that it's obviously
going on every serious intelligence
agency is giving all options to their
leaders and one option is could we and
if so what would it take
to assassinate vladimir putin or
similarly i mean the idea that lindsay's
talking about is someone from inside
russia
any serious intelligence agency
that has
moles double agents whatever within
russia would be saying do we have anyone
inside of russia close enough to putin
that they could potentially assassinate
putin i'm not saying anyone is planning
to do it
i'm not saying that it should be done
i'm saying when you are in a position of
providing options to leadership you
provide every option
and almost always in situations like
this one of the options is could we kill
someone and could we do it with enough
plausible deniability that it can never
be traced back to us
however it's not something a senator
should say it's very stupid it's
extraordinarily dumb for lindsey graham
to say it but to just write it off and
pretend these conversations aren't being
had would be extraordinarily naive now
by the next day lindsay had completely
backed off
obviously someone got to him and they
were like yeah that's you can't say that
you can't say that and lindsay instead
said well we should really be looking at
arresting putin mr ambassador you're
supporting a war criminal in putin
your country is engaged in war crimes in
front of the entire world you're bombing
innocent civilians using banned
munitions you have a record your country
does of dropping barrel bombs on people
in syria you've destroyed czechsnia by
massive war crimes you're committing war
crimes
in the ukraine you need to apologize to
the world
for how putin has stolen your country
blind how they're dismembering a
neighboring democracy called the ukraine
how they're killing innocent men and
women other than continuing to say
the ukraine lindsay's basically right
about his allegations as to what's going
on and children
indiscriminate use of force and
violation of the geneva convention you
my friend are the one who needs to
apologize and when it comes to putin he
needs to go to jail okay so toning it
down very much from the assassination
talk to go to jail uh you could liken
this to
the previous night lindsay was drunk
texting and then the next day he sent an
email to smooth things smooth things
over okay and that's an analogy i'm not
saying literally he was drunk texting
the night before
so he's essentially right he was very
wrong to talk about the assassination
but let's let's be adults here obviously
countries the world over are saying
would we be able to pull off an
assassination and what would be the
risks and the rewards and the
implications and as i said earlier
three assassination attempts against
zelensky i don't believe that if you
kill zelensky you really change anything
about ukrainian resistance in fact i
think you might bolster it because they
would be so invigorated by what would be
the insane killing of their president i
do think on the other hand that uh
if you kill putin you you do in a sense
decapitate the russian uh movement the
russian invasion because so many people
in russia clearly don't even want to be
doing it so
that's what's going on and lindsay said
the wrong thing quite frankly
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our
longtime sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman